michael saylor the ceo of microstrategy
he went out and he created the playbook
for public companies to put bitcoin on
their balance sheet that's right as he
was the first public company to come out
and buy hundreds of millions of dollars
of bitcoin he created that playbook and
then open sourced it and explain to
people why he was going to use bitcoin
as their reserve asset in doing so he
kicked off a massive influx of attention
and also interest in other public
companies doing the exact same thing and
so just like michael saylor created that
public company playbook to adopt bitcoin
as a reserve asset i personally believe
we're watching dokuan and the terra
ecosystem do the exact same thing for
fiat currencies or stable coins now what
am i talking about well tara has a
stable coin called ust and in it they
have just over two and a half billion
dollars worth of reserves over the last
couple of months and what they've
decided is that rather than having a
truly algorithmic stable coin they're
gonna go ahead and back their stable
coin with bitcoin here's exactly what
they're gonna do they're taking about
three billion dollars to start and
they're converting it into bitcoin
that'll sit in the reserves of that
stable coin and they believe that
they'll end up buying up to 10 billion
dollars over the coming months
just today this morning tara went ahead
and the luna foundation which is
actually conducting the purchases they
just purchased 100 million dollars more
of bitcoin they've been buying anywhere
between 100 million and 125 million of
bitcoin almost on a daily basis and if
you do that day in day out you continue
to make bitcoin more and more illiquid
they're buyers only they're not selling
and so they're providing a persistent
bid in the bitcoin market now if we go
ahead and we take a look all of their
reserves are transparent you can see
inside of that foundation reserve they
have 2.26 billion dollars in their total
reserve balance 1.7 billion dollars is
in bitcoin and they have about 4.3
million tokens in that reserve as well
not only can we see what the reserve
balances are in that transparent way but
we can literally go to the blockchain we
can validate it here's what i'm talking
about you can see right here that's that
wallet and you can see that they
currently hold 42 407 bitcoin about 1.7
billion dollars worth of bitcoin right
there transparent for anyone in the
world to validate and audit at any point
in time that's the beauty of the bitcoin
blockchain and so regardless of what you
think whether you think that luna's a
scam or not whether you like ust or not
doesn't matter because ultimately the
free market is gonna decide what to do
with this attempt to back a stablecoin
with bitcoin in the reserves if they are
successful i believe that they will
create the playbook for central banks
and stablecoin issuers around the world
to go ahead and replicate this if
they're not successful we'll probably
learn something along the way there's
risk in everything but i still think
that the experimentation and the
attempted innovation by dokuan and the
terra ecosystem is very very important
how do we know whether this works or not
until someone tries it well that's
exactly what we're gonna find out and i
hope that they're successful because if
they can create a playbook hopefully
eventually every central bank will have
an escape route they're under immense
pressure right now
and they need something to back their
fiat currencies with over time and
bitcoin is pristine collateral and my
guess is that doe quan is going to show
them the way to make bitcoin the reserve
asset of the world hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time